fighting for love on TV could be quite
stressful so we teamed up with secrets
resorts and spas to give some of our
favorite reality TV couples a week of
unparalleled pampering and unlimited
luxury so it's been an amazing trip and
we wanted to cap it all off with the
perfect treatment for you guys this is
the signature massage involving wine
therapy you can choose between
Chardonnay Merlot champagne guys enjoy
Jared I feel like you were really
looking for this this was my favorite
part of the entire vacation the
chocolate-covered strawberries the
champagne and a hot tub yeah right there
you guys are so busy Evan and Carly you
have a new little baby at home
Ashley and Jared you guys are planning a
wedding what do you guys do though to
treat each other to a little luxury
moment it's one time Jared gave up his
first-class ticket for me on a plane so
that was really really kind of luxurious
he gives up first class I think ours is
as simple as like Carly's like can't
even wash my hair can you watch her love
language six hours but
you
[Music]